ابدا معك عامر لافي في اسطنبول التي بلغت
نسبه المشاركه فيها اكثر من
83% خسرها اردوغان
بفارق بسيط ما اسباب عدم تمكن اردوغان من
حسم اسطنبول لصالحه
نعم وسيله بالفعل هذه المدينه المدينه
الاكبر في تركيا خزان الاصوات التي يعني
حاول اردوغان ان يستعيدها بعد الجوله
الاولى لكن الذي جرى هو ان كمالك لن اقول
ضعفه ولكنه زاد من الفارق بينه وبين رجب
طيب اردوغان في الجوله الاولى كان الفارق
تقريبا 190 الف صوت لكن في الجوله الثانيه
تجاوز الفارق حوالي اكثر من 300 الف صوت
لكن بالمجمل يبقى الفارق ضئيلا جدا عندما
نتحدث عن مدينه تمتلك 11 مليون صوت
وبالتالي استطاع اردوغان ان يعوض هذا
الفارق بسهوله من خلال رفع اصواته في اكثر
من تسع محافظات كانت في الجوله الاولى قد
كانت لصالح كمال كل دارو له الاسباب في
الاجابه عن سؤالك وسيله هناك العديد من
الاسباب على راسها
السبب الاقتصادي والازمه الاقتصاديه التي
طالت كل شرائح المجتمع التركي في عموم
تركيا لكنها كانت واضحه بشكل كبير هنا في
اسطنبول هذه المدينه الكبيره الاسعار فيها
الضعاف او ربما اعلى بكثير من المدن
الاخرى وبالتالي كانت تاثير على الناس هنا
كثير مضاعف دعيني اقوله وبالتالي هذا
جعلهم يستجيبون لدعواتكم كما يقول كثير من
المراقبين الذي وعد بتحسين الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه الامر الاخر نسبه الشباب
المتزايده هنا والتي طبعا هنا لابد من
الاشاره الى ان هذه النسبه اشيئه عنها
الكثير والمعارضه ومن خلال وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي كانت تتحدث عن ان خمسه مليون
شاب يدلون باصواتهم لاول مره منذ انتخابات
2018 هؤلاء في مجملهم رافضين لحكم حزب
العداله والتنميه وللرئيس اردوغان وان
هؤلاء سيصوتون لرجب طيب اردوغان نعم هناك
جزء هذا مطابحه بعد ذلك جزء جيد من هؤلاء
لا يريد اردو لكن ليس كما كانت المعارضه
تسوق والا كان من الصعب على اردوغان ان
يفوز بهذه الانتخابات هؤلاء صنعوا ايضا
جزءا مهما من الفارق في هذه المدينه التي
يوجد فيها اعداد كبيره من الشباب وبالتالي
هذا الجزء الذي صوت لكمال كريش دارولو هو
الذي اعطى هذا الفارق وجعل هذه المدينه
تذهب لصالح كمالكيش دارولو الامر الاخر
والمهم هو ان حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي الذي
محسوب على انه يوصف بانه الذراع السياسي
لحزب العمال كردستاني دعا مناصريه ليصوتوا
لكم في هذه المدينه وفي عموم تركيا كما
تعلمين وبالتالي هذا ما احدث ايضا فارقا
مهما جدا لانه اذا نظرنا الى الانتخابات
البرلمانيه في الرابع عشر من مايو الماضي
كان الذي فاز في اسطنبول وبفارق كبير هو
تحالف الجمهور بقياده حزب العداله
والتنميه ورجب طيب اردوغان لماذا لان هذا
الحزب ومناصريه هذا الحزب ادلوا باصواتهم
لص لكي يحصل على مقاعد في البرلمان بينما
فقط ادلب باصواتهم في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
لكم وبالتالي حدث فرق كبير الفارق في
الانتخابات البرلمانيه لتحالف الجمهور
بقياده رجب طيب اردوغان تقريبا اكبر من ما
حصل عليه تحالف الشعبي خمسه بالمئه
وبالتالي فارق كبير جدا اتحدث طبعا على
الانتخابات البرلمانيه التي طبعا لم تنعكس
على الانتخابات الرئاسيه كما قلنا للاسباب
التي ذكرت هذه الاسباب اختم وسيله
المعارضه في قبل الانتخابات حاولت ان تسوق
لان هذه الاسباب ليس فقط موضوع الشباب كل
هذه الاسباب هي عوامل قوه بيدها وانها
ستغير النظام التي كانت تصفه بالاستبداد
وبالدكتاتوري وان الازمه الاقتصاديه
والشباب والدعم من احزاب كثيره واحزاب
يعني كما تعلمين الطاوله السداسيه
بالاضافه الى الاحزاب التي دعمتها من
الخارج اعتبرت وكانت تسوق الى ان
هذا التحالف وهذه العوامل ستجعل هناك
تغيير في هذه في في تركيا وتحديدا طبعا في
اسطنبول التي طالما ردد الاتراك ومعروف
عنها كلمه الذي يفوز باسطنبول يفوز في
عموم تركيا نعم فازت المعارضه لكنها لم
تفوز في عموم تركيا لان الفرق كان ضئيلا
واستطاع رجب طيب اردوغان ان يملا هذا
الفارغ كما ذكرنا باصوات العديد من المدن
التي فاز فيها